hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well among the five
intellectual virtues that Aristotle
discusses in his Nicomachean ethics book
cyst treatment of the intellectual
virtues one of them is what in Greek is
a pista main we often translate this as
either just knowledge or scientific
knowledge sometimes as science sometimes
disciplinary knowledge that's one of my
favorite translations to try to render
it and Arizona doesn't tell us quite as
much about this he has he does some of
the other intellectual virtues
particularly from Asus but that's in
part because he's he's more concerned
with the practical than with the
theoretical as such that said he does
think that knowledge in this sense plays
a very important role it is an
excellence of the soul of virtue and I
retain it is a habit that has to be
built up over time he says this is
something that we can acquire through
learning and be taught and a piston a
and if he has to do with the part of the
soul that is concerned with
things that whose first principles don't
change here Osama will actually say and
one point that the mr. BAE and some of
the other higher intellectual virtues
are concerned with those things that are
of greatest dignity in nature that is
you know in many respects the heavens
you know the nature of mind itself the
nature of the gods whatever that happens
to be a little unclear for Aristotle
those sorts of matters so it's concerned
with contemplation
theoria and the verb that he usually
typically uses there is there a game and
it's concerned with a truth but not
truth in action not truth about how to
get things done what he calls the truth
of a thought or just truth per se so
this is detached from at least for
Aristotle detached from practical
implications it could bear upon the
practical matters that could inform
practical matters but the pista made by
itself does not does not actually do
that so he goes on and he says that it
deals with what cannot be different that
is doesn't admit of being in a different
condition I love Santa to be to to exist
to you know it's its configuration in a
different state that means to be
fundamentally different so piston make
can study things that do change for
example physics or before biology
biology or studying animals and plants
and by extension human beings logic you
know some propositions may have their
truth value change depending on what
they're they're referring to but is it's
you know the the basic principles that
are being discovered don't in fact
change why because the Archaea the
starting points the the principles the
beginnings of them also don't change he
tells us that the histamine
has to do in particular with what we
nowadays translate as universals this is
the Greek term for that as tone tokaku
loom you know well Toni capital mu total
capital do the comma blue means
something like in every case with
respect to the whole with with respect
to everything right it's over by the way
that we get Catholic from you say
somebody has Catholic tastes that means
they encompass everything so it deals
with universals it deals with the things
as they're understood by reason or by
the intellect with the kind of thing
that they are not so much with the
individual particular thing
science is not quite so interested in
that he says it also deals with the
things that are by necessity or out of
necessity
excellent man case that's why it deals
with things they have typically remain
the same even though perhaps you know
the individual instances may change the
general things don't change why because
there's some sort of necessity some sort
of compulsion some sort of it has to be
this way there and that's what allows
one to discover something that can be
assembled into a body of scientific
knowledge it is reliable it stays the
same over time now he also says that it
reasons from what are called first
principles from argot and it does so
primarily in a deductive fashion
deductive is a term that we we use in
English it's coming from Latin and it's
used to translate aquadecks us in Greek
which means something like a a you know
process of deductive demonstration it's
often translated as demonstration you
know literally it means to like just lay
it to you know lay things out in such a
way that they're shown there they're you
know comes from the word to show and
Arizona says
when it comes to first principles we we
don't grasp first principles deductively
deduction is the kind of you know you
know reasoning that comes from necessity
where it is written you know in a logic
textbook you'll often run across the
distinction deductive and inductive
arguments and they'll say the in
deductive arguments is the premises are
true the conclusion must be true that's
what we're saying here with this that's
not to say that scientific knowledge
can't have any measure of in induction
or whatever so it calls up our game yeah
but it's primarily deductive and so it
has to get its starting points it's you
know principles its premises from
somewhere else where is that somewhere
else well you know herb it could be
through through observation you know
through what we call experience or
perception but in large part the
principles for scientific knowledge are
actually going to be coming to it at
least for the people who are you know
truly carrying it out from news or
intellect or intelligence another one of
the intellectual virtues now of course
the learner working within a particular
system may not actually grasp the first
principles as such they may sort of take
them on faith and just sort of
deductively reason from there and that
is often okay as they're teaching what
would be some examples of scientific
knowledge because you know we didn't
talk about this in the singular but then
we can also talk about this in plural
one person may have one kind of
scientific knowledge without possessing
another kind of scientific knowledge
right especially in our own day
Aristotle was somebody who was quite a
polymath he learned a lot of different
things but that is often not the case
for the human beings that we know and to
observe isn't it they're often quite
specialized well mathematics would be a
prime example of this mathematics is in
some respects the piston made par
excellence
Aristotle actually observe
you get addicted McCann ethics book sex
okay you can teach kids math even though
he can't really teach him tactics much
or political science or metaphysics
because they don't have enough
experience mathematics is an example of
a science that proceeds from its it's
axioms it's it's starting points it's
it's arcane it's archived first
principles and then just deductively
reasons out from there it is true that
it can be applied to the world of
experience but pure mathematics is
indeed a very pure theoretical science
and so if it's the model of ourselves
talking about quite well physics and
biology physics Aristotle does quite a
lot of work in that field physics is the
science of change of things that undergo
moment or change they may say well how
can it be a science that well the basic
principles of it do not change and
Aristotle is concerned with in this you
know world of things that we observe
changing what are the underlying
principles that we find you know making
everything work in more or less the same
way that's to figure out what's going on
universally or by necessity
similarly with biology living things
what can we say about those who are
subtle devote several books to that
logic not a term that Aristotle uses by
the way he doesn't talk about hey Logan
kid but that he usually means the
rational logical but he does leave
behind several important works in logic
and argumentation which also do in fact
tell us about a pista may as a form of
inquiry those would be things like the
analytics the topics works along those
lines the basic principles of those
sorts of activities as opposed to for
example say rhetoric which Aristotle
treats as a technic and that is the
science but is
Earth's or a craft those can all be
understood in terms again of the
universals or what is by necessity so
this is the aerosol takes a valuable
state or a habit of mine each of these
would be itself sort of a manifestation
of this general habit of scientific
knowledge one of the intellectual
virtues